we might be closing out 2019 but there's
a whole new year of free games with gold
coming in 2020 if you are an Xbox Live
Gold member and want to know what you
can grab in January I've got you covered
kicking off the new year on Xbox one is
Styx master of Shadows this stealth game
puts you in the shoes of Styx an orc who
can turn invisible clone himself and see
hidden enemies his weapons and abilities
improve via RPG skill trees - you can
slip into the shadows any time as Styx
will be available to download all
January loan
Batman stalks through the shadows - and
the telltale series is Xbox ones other
new offering in telltale fashion you'll
make dialog choices and take actions
that change the plot over the course of
five episodes you can check out tell
tales take on the quintessential caped
hero and download Batman from January
16th through February 15th on the 360
side you can throw down with Tekken 6
the ever-popular fighting games sports
41 playable characters and this entry
features a rage system that makes your
fighters stronger when their health gets
low there's also an additional beat'em
up mode if you'd rather throw fists with
a bunch of low-level thugs Tekken 6 will
be available January 1st through the
15th just in time for rise of Skywalker
Xbox 360s other game is lego star wars -
the original trilogy this takes the Lego
game formula of beating up bad guys
solving puzzles and building all sorts
of contraptions to the original Star
Wars films a new hope the Empire Strikes
Back and Return of the Jedi it'll be
available to download from January 16th
through the 31st and thanks to backwards
compatibility
both this and Tekken can be played on
Xbox one as well and those are your free
games with gold for January 2020
remember that you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on GameSpot and stay tuned as we
report on the new games with gold lineup
every month
[Music]